MALE SPEAKER: Dr. Hargraves
has written articles and made
presentations about the
Liquid Fluoride Thorine
Reactor-- or LFTR, as we
affectionately call it--
and energy cheaper than
coal, the only realistic way
to dissuade nations from
burning fossil fuels.
His presentation, "Aim
High," about the technology
and social benefits
of LFTR, has been
presented to
audiences at Institute
for Lifelong Education
at Dartmouth College,
Thayer School of Engineering,
Brown University, Columbia
Earth Institute, Williams
College, Royal Institution,
the Thorium Energy Alliance,
the International Thorium Energy
Association, Google-- at
Mountain View in both 2009
and 2010-- the American
Nuclear Society,
The President's Blue Ribbon
Commission of America's Nuclear
Future, and the Chinese
Academy of Sciences.
With co-author Ralph Moir,
he has written articles
for the American Physical
Society Forum on Physics
and Society, "Liquid
Fuel Nuclear Reactors"--
that was January 2011--
and "American Scientist,"
"Liquid Fluoride Thorium
Reactors," July 2010.
Robert is a study
leader for energy policy
at Dartmouth Ilead.
He was chief information
officer at Boston Scientific
Corporation, and previously
a senior consultant
with Arthur D. Little.
He founded software firm
DTSS Incorporated while
at Dartmouth
College, where he was
assistant professor
of mathematics
and associate director of
the computation center.
He graduated from Brown
University with a Ph.D.
In physics in 1967,
and Dartmouth College,
AB mathematics and
physics in 1961.
It is with appreciation
that we welcome
Robert to speak
to us here today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Well,
besides the climate crisis,
we have an economic crisis.
Here's an example
of it in India.
You can look at that picture and
see that the Indian economy is
not doing particularly well.
You also notice that they are
collecting biofuels, which
is not really an environmentally
friendly activity.
The other thing to
notice is that that's not
a great source of energy.
And another thing to notice
is that these are all women--
women who are quite
under-employed in this country.
So there are a lot
of problems that
are encapsulated in this photo
that we want to try to address.
First thing to notice,
though, is government debts.
It's not just the US
that has a debt crisis.
It's many of the
nations on earth
have a growing debt compared to
their gross domestic product.
It's not just us.
How do we solve that problem?
We have the risk of
default on the debt.
We have a potential
risk of inflation,
if we all print more money.
GDP might contract, destruction
of people's savings,
and the collapse of the
welfare state in Europe.
There are solutions
that are proposed.
The conservatives and
Republicans generally say,
let's cut back on spending.
That's the way to
solve the debt crisis.
The more liberal
economists would say, well,
let's spend more money and
get us out of this situation
by sparking economic growth
with deficit spending.
Or perhaps we should devalue
the dollar and export more.
But that doesn't work if
all the countries do that.
That's a zero-sum game.
So what can you do instead?
One example is
productivity growth.
And you all in the IT industry
should remember the Y2K crisis.
During that crisis, which
was caused by people
worrying about the two-digit
year number not being enough,
and causing failures and
control systems and so on,
many CEOs of Fortune 500
companies were scared.
So they invested tons
of money in products
like Google's system.
Or SAP for
enterprise-wide software
to control everything
from personnel
to purchasing to production
control, bills and materials--
the whole package, in multiple
locations, multiple currencies.
In fact, that
investment paid off.
It did increase GDP.
It's one of the factors that
was responsible for the growth
in economic
productivity in the US
in the early part
of this century.
So what about the idea
of productivity growth
to cheap energy,
instead of new software?
Cheap energy can make
a big difference.
We'll talk about that.
Meanwhile, we have a few
crises sitting in front of us.
We have the iconic polar bear,
symbolizing global warming.
We have world population growing
from perhaps seven billion
today to nine or more.
We're running out of food.
The fish in the
ocean are largely
depleted-- at least the large
ones that we like to eat.
And don't forget we have
wars over natural resources.
This is a picture
of a war in Kuwait,
where Iraq invaded for oil
and then burned the oil
wells on the way out.
So the competition for natural
resources-- particularly,
energy is a problem.
Coal emissions in
the US, according
to the Environmental
Protection Agency,
and according to the local
Cambridge Clean Air Task Force
Group, says that there
are 13,000 deaths a year
from respiratory illnesses
caused by inhalation
of small particulates, 2.5
microns in diameter and less.
There are perhaps
a half a million
or a million such deaths
in China and other places
where the particulates
are even larger.
In the case of global
warming, my concern
mostly is food production.
This is an example
of the Rongbuk
Glacier in India, decades apart.
In one case, we had lots
of ice flowing down.
In the other case,
it's nearly dry.
The glaciers are the
source of summer meltwater
that enables
agriculture to thrive
year round in these places.
The loss of this
kind of water supply
is a threat to food
supply worldwide.
Now, that's my biggest
take on global warming.
This is a chart of data that
was compiled by the CIA.
On the horizontal axis
are, for each nation
in the picture, the number of
children per women birthed,
on the average.
And on the vertical axis,
the gross domestic product
per capita, which is very
closely related to income.
One of the things
you should notice,
just looking at it instantly,
is that the stable replacement
rate of about 2.2
births per woman
is only exceeded in the
poorest countries in the world.
Those countries that
are relatively well off
from a GDP per
capita point of view
have a sustainable, or
diminishing, birth rate.
So prosperity is an important
stabilizer for population.
If we look closely
here, we notice
that that occurs at somewhere
around $7,500 per year,
gross domestic
product per capita.
That's the number
we'd like to get to.
If we could do that, it
appears we could really
stabilize the
earth's population.
Why?
Because women who are
in prosperous countries
have time to get
off their chores,
time to relax, time to go
to school, time to get jobs,
time to have money of their
own and exert the independence
they need to control births.
Prosperity has cut
the birth rate.
Prosperity is also largely
dependent upon energy.
Now, energy's not
the only component
to make a prosperous nation.
We need good government.
We need the rule of law.
We need education.
But we also critically
need energy.
And, specifically, we
need electric energy--
the kind of power you need for
refrigeration, for commerce,
for transportation, for
safety, for machine tools.
Everything depends upon
that rather useful form
of energy, electric power.
And here, it's about-- again,
about 2,000 kilowatt hours
per capita seems
to be a number that
is associated with the
level of prosperity
needed to control population.
For comparison, the US
is off the chart here.
We're at about 12,000
kilowatt hours per person.
Canada, 14,000.
And occasional countries have
even more electric consumption.
But somewhere around 2,000
kilowatt hours, or 600 watts
average power per
person, seems to be
a number that suggests
achieving the prosperity
for stable population.
The other thing to
notice is that prosperity
depends upon cheap energy.
This is a "Wall
Street Journal" chart.
And the arrows pointing
down to the vertical bars
indicate when we've
had recessions.
And there's an indication
that when oil prices spike,
there's a strong
correlation with
diminished economic performance.
Several economists tried to
model the economic behavior
as a function of labor, and
capital, and energy, and so on.
And their conclusions
are that if you
were to take a big world
economy and inject,
for free, about a dollar's worth
of energy in the form of oil
into it, you can
increase the productivity
of the whole economy
by about five to one.
We still have cheap oil.
It can't stay cheap, though.
Here's the total investments
of the major oil companies
over the last 10 years or so.
It's quintupled!
So if you're spending that much
money to explore for new oil,
the prices have
only got to go up.
Now, developing
nations know full well
that electric power
and energy are
critical to their
economic development.
And so they are
desperately seeking
to get new energy sources.
Coal plants-- there are
something like 1,400 gigawatts
of coal plants in production
around the world today.
And although we kind
of think in the US
we are diminishing that number,
as we pass laws and the coal
plants shut here--
some of them--
the number of coal plants
worldwide, under planning,
is going to double.
It's going to be another
1,400 watts of power,
doubling CO2 emissions.
So that's the reality of
the projections worldwide.
What we do in the US
is not so important,
compared to what the developing
nations are going to do.
A lot of people say, well,
we ought to pass carbon taxes
and get the developing nations
to not burn so much energy.
But the developing nations
like China say, wait a minute.
The US and the OECD nations
gained their prosperity
by cheap energy
from burning coal.
Now it's our turn.
How can you say that you
achieved your prosperity,
and we can't?
Here's this CO2 emissions per
capita of the United States--
a little over 1,000
tons per person.
China says, well, we've
only done 76 tons.
When we get to 1,000,
we'll talk about it.
And that same story will be
repeated in India, Indonesia,
and so on.
Economics is a powerful force.
I like Fareed Zakaria.
He's got a book.
And he tries to point out
the importance of economics.
And a very mundane thing is
change economics and trade
over the last few decades.
And that's the container.
The container ship has
made world commerce
possible-- inexpensively,
without pilferage,
in a standardized form.
That trade takes place between
a whole network of 250 nations.
So the occasional
bilateral treaty
we sign to stop some
sort of behavior
we don't like about energy
doesn't matter much.
Economics always works
around these things.
Economics is the most
powerful force, not politics
We need energy
cheaper than coal.
We tried politics
to contain CO2.
But nations resist carbon taxes.
Even a wealthy nation,
like the United States,
will not pass a carbon tax.
And yet, we have conferences
where people go and talk
about how to have a political
agreement to pass carbon taxes.
And here are all some
of the recent failed
conferences that led nowhere.
And yet, we keep trying
to do that again.
We need energy
cheaper than coal.
That's the only way we can
stop people from burning coal.
Provide them with a more
attractive and more economical
alternative.
A lot of people say,
well, why don't we
just cut back on our power use?
We're gluttons here.
We're using too much energy.
And perhaps we are.
In the US, we generate and
use about 434 gigawatts
of power on the average,
throughout the year.
So let's suppose that
we are really good
and we cut back our electric
power use to half of that.
And then the rest of
the nations in the world
who want to achieve that
good standard of living
we have in the US also achieve
that level of use per capita.
That's the projected
electric power consumption
for the world, if that
scenario I described is true.
So again, what we do in the
US is important, a little bit.
But what the earth
depends on mostly
is what the rest
of the world does,
because there's so
many people there.
We need energy cheaper
than coal, again.
Now, in the book, I went
through a little scenario
to do a very crude model of
the costs of electric power
from various sources.
And this is going to
summarize these things.
I break costs into three
components-- capital cost
recovery for the investment
in the power plant,
the fuel it takes, and the
operations cost and so on.
Now, given an investment in a
power plant like a coal power
plant, a brand-new costs on
the order of $2.80 for capital
investment for every watt of
capacity that that coal plant
will have.
So we want to convert
that capital cost
to the expense of
recovering that capital.
So we want to know what is the
equivalent payment to achieve
that $2.80 investment.
And you have to learn a little
bit about present value,
if you haven't done that.
The question is, would
I like $1,000 now?
Or would I like a penny an
hour for the next 40 years?
The answer to that depends upon
the discount rate you choose.
And people can argue about that.
I picked, in this example, 8%.
But you can do the
math any way you like.
And I also picked a lifetime
for most things of 40 years.
In the case of coal plants
and nuclear power plants,
I picked a capacity
factor-- that
is, the time it's
running-- of 90%.
That is, you only
get your penny back
when the plant's
actually running.
Doing that, the
math is really easy.
Because $2.80 per watt
investment turns out to be 2.8
cents per kilowatt hours.
So the math is easy.
OK, we'll use that I model.
In the lower left of this
screen is the only running plant
that actually has the
ability to capture CO2.
It's an integrated
gasification combined cycle.
It's the kind of
power plant that
burns coal in oxygen,
instead of air.
So there's no nitrogen oxides
in the fuel, or no nitrogen.
It makes it easy to extract the
CO2 from the exhaust stream,
because it's only water and CO2.
But it was very
expensive to build.
There's only one been built.
That cost was about
$4.76 per watt,
just for the capital
cost of the plant,
without storing
the CO2 anywhere.
Just in the last week, we
saw announcements in the "MIT
Technology Review" of two new
plants in Louisiana and Canada
that have a capital cost
in excess of $9 per watt,
just to get the CO2 out,
not to dispose of it.
So carbon capture
and storage, which
has been touted by the coal
companies as clean coal,
is economically infeasible.
Natural gas-- that's
the current darling.
A couple of things here.
One is that the capital cost
for natural gas power plants
is relatively low, on
the order of $1 per watt,
for the capacity.
And the fuel, right,
today is relatively cheap.
Fuel has been as low as
$2 or $3 a million BTUs.
And now it's up to five, about.
And that number-- 2.8
cents a kilowatt hour--
is the contribution
of the fuel cost.
Again, I just said operations
cost in this really simple
model are $1-- a penny
per kilowatt hour.
You can do better.
But, I mean, that's to maintain
the generator, and the power
station, and the transformers,
and all that sort of thing.
That's not unreasonable.
Again, a simple model.
Couple other
points, though-- one
is that most of the
gas plants in the US
are the ones that were
designed to do peaking.
That is, to come online
fast, speed up the power,
and generate electricity.
And their efficiency
is only about 30%.
That is, 30% of the
potential thermal energy
for burning the fuel is
converted into electric power.
Whereas the fancier ones
that are combined cycle that
have the gas turbines, for
which the turbine heats water
to make steam in a
secondary generation scheme,
are about 60%.
Much more so-- a bit
more expensive to run,
a lot more conservative
of fuel, but they
take hours to start up,
as opposed to minutes.
So they're not used for
backing up wind power.
They're used as energy sources.
They're pretty good.
So that's the situation
with natural gas.
In the case of wind,
it's very hard,
because you read all the
newspapers about how cheap it
is and how it keeps dropping.
OK, my approach was to try and
find out what the total capital
investment was to
create a wind farm.
Not the wind farm
after the subsidies,
after the renewable
energy credits,
after the capital tax
writedowns, and so on.
Try and find out the real
cost, the total cost--
because it doesn't
matter who paid.
From a society point of view,
or from a global point of view,
it doesn't matter whether it was
the taxpayer, the rate payer,
the bondholder-- whoever
put the money in.
The question is, as a society,
we need to do the right thing.
Because we're talking
about a global problem.
So find out that total
cost, if you can.
Here's some cost
estimates from the EIA--
the Energy Information Agency
of the Department of Energy,
which is usually pretty good.
Their example is $2.44 a watt.
But if you look at the price
for the Deepwater Horizon--
Deepwater Wind farm, off
the coast of Rhode Island,
that was $7 a watt.
Right nearby, Cape
Wind is $5.80 for watt.
Their capacity factor
is only 30%, though.
So to do the capital
cost recovery, remember,
we only would cover
that capital cost
when the wind is
generating electricity.
So you have to divide that
capital cost by .03 in order
to figure that out.
Now--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] number
for the table on the left?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
I think so.
I think that's the
number I picked.
The Cape Wind cost
of the utility,
as a sort of a reasonableness
check, is in this range.
They signed contracts with the
utilities in Massachusetts.
They have an escalation cause.
And they'll go up to $0.24
an hour, if that happens.
So the model's not crazy.
It's about right.
All right.
So electricity-- same idea.
Here's that Ivanpah plant at
Brightsource, is the company.
OK, there again, capital
cost recovery-- figuring out,
in this case, I think I used
25% percent capacity factor.
We have to look in the book.
$0.22 a kilowatt hour.
Fuel is cheap.
Ops are about a penny.
Again, here are some
examples of capital costs.
And here are some examples
of contracted power costs,
but for which the company
sells power to the utilities.
So the utilities have been
bludgeoned by law and public
utilities into purchasing
wind power and solar power
at the prices-- OK--
were the first priority.
And thereafter, go and
buy natural gas, or coal,
or nuclear, or whatever.
And here again are some prices
that are being paid today.
AllEarth is-- I don't know if
[INAUDIBLE] is up and running.
AllEarth is getting paid
$0.30 a kilowatt hour.
Remember, coal is about 5.6%,
nuclear typically around $0.06
today.
Biomass-- people say,
well, that's renewable.
Let's try that.
OK, so I looked again
at some examples
of what these units
cost to build.
And here are a couple examples.
The fuel, well, delivered to
the plant is those numbers.
I called up and I found out what
it costs to buy tons of wood.
And put it in a plan.
Figure out how many BTUs
you get out of the wood.
And run through the
efficiency calculation.
And we get fuel costs about
$0.47 a kilowatt hour.
So again, the total-- $0.09.
So my conclusion is,
green energy is not
cheaper than coal.
Here's a summary of
what we just covered,
right-- on the far left, coal.
Gas today is a little
cheaper than coal.
That's why coal use has
been diminishing somewhat.
And we can probably see that
happening for a few more years.
But the others are
more expensive.
Again, the reason the press
reports their cheapness
is because of
unstated subsidies.
For example, AllEarth
renewables in Vermont--
the capital cost of that
plant was paid for 30%
by the federal government
as a tax credit.
Not only that-- the tax
credits, by special exemption,
were not paid at the
time the taxes were paid.
They were paid
upfront, in advance.
The state of Vermont
gave a 30% capital
tax credit to that organization.
They get a $0.24 per kilowatt
hour production tax credit.
They get priority on the grid.
They can always sell it.
The utility must take that
power whenever they can.
And so on.
And they get $0.30 a kilowatt
hour for the electricity they
do sell.
So here's my calculation.
Do your own.
When you're curious, try and
find out what the plant costs.
Figure out what the
capital cost is, really.
And spread it out over
the lifetime and capacity
factor of the plant.
So here's carbon intensity
of the electric power sector
worldwide.
It hasn't changed a bit.
So I say, green doesn't work.
Can nuclear work?
Well, back to
nuclear for a second.
Alvin Weinberg is a
guy who patented--
or was co-patentor-- of the
light water reactor that
was used originally in
Rickover's submarine, and today
in all the US power plants and
most of the ones worldwide.
Rickover was a dynamic and
forceful and obnoxious person
who managed to get it
installed in the submarines
and also was tapped
by Eisenhower to lead
the domestic nuclear
power program.
And he basically
took the same design
and was going on an
aircraft carrier, put it
in a shipping port
in Pennsylvania.
And that was the seed for all of
the power plants, nuclear power
plants that were
built there after.
Not only that-- the Navy
was training admirals
and generals-- not generals,
admirals and captains and so
on-- to run these
nuclear power plants.
And it was a source and supply
of skilled nuclear technical
people to run the
power plants on land.
But what about yesterday's
solid fuel nuclear reactors?
Can they compete
with natural gas?
Last year, this plant, out
of the blue, shut down.
They said their operations
costs alone were such
that they couldn't
make money competing
against natural gas,
which surprises me.
I'm still flabbergasted
why it was so expensive.
At that time, gas
was about-- was
making 4.3 cents electricity.
They couldn't do it,
even incrementally.
They shut the plant.
And once you shut it,
it's basically gone.
Right locally in
Vermont, this plant
is shutting down at
the end of the year.
Same argument--
can't make money.
So what about the new power
plants, the new generation 3
plus plants that
Westinghouse is now building?
Two in Georgia, and
two in the Carolinas.
That plant costs $6
per watt of capacity.
So it looks to me
like it's going
to generate electric
power somewhere
around $0.08 a kilowatt hour.
Well, remember coal is about
$0.56, so that's kind of tough.
So that doesn't look
too promising yet,
unless we can get the
cost of those points down.
Which, by the way, China is.
Westinghouse is building
those same plants in China,
and their capital cost
for the first ones
are $2 per watt, not $6.
So there's something different
about the costs in the US.
Those of you who like Bill
Gates and his investments
in TerraPower--
remember, he's building
a kind of a power plant, which
is cooled by liquid metal.
It's a so-called fast reactor.
In the US, that program was
called integral fast reactor
at one time.
This is a
PriceWaterhouseCoopers estimate
of the cost of power from that.
Gates would say he's
aiming to compete
with other nuclear power plants.
But it's certainly
not cheaper than coal.
So we need innovation.
Let's look at the space program
as a source of cost innovation.
SpaceX-- remember
Elon Musk, right?
And things like
PayPal, and SpaceX,
and Tesla, and all
those good things.
He saw a cost-innovation
opportunity there,
because of the
shuttle complexity.
And because of the fact
they used 1970s technology.
Now, that kind of
rings a bell when
you think about light water
reactors in the United States.
So what he did was assemble a
small team with low overhead
and design an entirely
new rocket engine.
And do it quickly.
Between the time
of incorporation
and the first rocket
flight was only six years.
The SpaceX Falcon, which
is their first product,
flew for $443 million--
compared to the NASA estimate
for what it was going
to cost NASA to do it
if the government did that
project at $1.44 billion.
So he's proving
that sometimes there
is a technical
cost-innovation opportunity.
What about liquid fuel reactors
instead of solid fuel reactors?
That's my idea.
This is a picture of a liquid
fuel reactor at Oak Ridge
National Laboratory.
It's a lot of pipes,
and the reactor
in the sort of top middle,
on the right a little bit.
Oak Ridge started
this way back in 1953.
This man, Richard
Engel, is still
a consultant in this area.
He, at that time, was putting
together a water reactor.
That is heavy water that had
dissolved in a uranium sulfite
salt.
And it generated electric
power, as a power plant.
Had all the things
about stability
and so on that we like.
They couldn't make it really
big enough to generate
commercial power.
But that was their
first adventure
in liquid fuel reactors.
Thereafter, Weinberg-- the guy
who invented the light water
reactor-- also was the
director of Oak Ridge
and a designer and promoter
of the molten salt reactor.
So, in this case, the
liquid was not water.
It was salt that was melted.
And the salt was a
fluoride-- fluorides
of lithium, or beryllium,
and so on-- picked
because they have
low atomic numbers.
And picked because the
fluoride-- fluorine
doesn't absorb neutrons.
So they ran a reactor
way back in '54
at a red-hot temperature.
A current reactor is what,
300 degrees centigrade or so?
This is quite hot.
So the proof of concept worked.
Later on, after a
lot of machinations,
they tried to put
together one that
was going to be more
commercially oriented
and that also worked
in that time period.
Here's kind of how
these things work.
Here's a chart of the nuclides.
The horizontal axis
is the atomic number,
the number of protons.
The vertical axis is
the atomic weight,
the number of
neutrons plus protons.
Right in the middle
of the chart,
you see the U-235
symbol for fission.
But if we look up at the
top, on the 238 line,
you can see that
uranium 238, which
is 96% of all the uranium that's
in a power plant reactor today.
That uranium, when it absorbs
a neutron in that blue arrow
symbol, it becomes
U-2-- I'm sorry.
It becomes U-239,
which is unstable.
And over a period of
days, it decays, finally
to become plutonium 239,
which is a fissile material.
And that fissile
material, in turn,
fissions and generates heat
and power in a reactor.
Few people realize that
in today's power reactors,
we're not only
fissioning uranium 235.
A third of the power at
the end of the fuel cycle
is from plutonium.
We actually manufacture
and burn plutonium
right in the solid fuel reactor.
In the same scheme,
Weinberg and crew
pointed out that
thorium 232, when
irradiated in the same
scheme, becomes uranium 233,
another fissile material.
So there's another avenue
and has a technical reason
why that's sort of convenient.
And that is, it can happen
at low neutron energies.
So that's what's happening.
Now, we can actually design
one of these reactors.
So this is a kind
of a busy diagram.
OK, so that big,
yellow circle is
meant to be the reactor,
a liquid pot or vessel.
And there's a lot of reactions
that go on inside there.
At the top left is an
example of a U-233 fission
which releases neutrons.
And those neutrons have
a couple of purposes.
One is they can promote
something like U-238
to become plutonium 239, which
could be fissioned and make
power, just as the
U-235 or anything else
can release neutrons
when fissioned
and promote 232 thorium
to becomes fissile U-233.
So it's a good scheme.
It's very-- relatively
inexpensive to construct.
It's a highly
proliferation-resistant scheme
of things, more so even
than today's reactors.
And I'm a fan of
this reactor today,
because I think we can build
it relatively inexpensively.
It will run for decades,
before eventually you
have to change the salt.
Meanwhile, at the
top left, there's
a waste-separator thing.
And some of the fission
products, like Xenon,
tend to absorb neutrons
and impede the reaction.
There's a scheme in
these kinds of reactors
to remove some of the
fission products on the fly,
in the liquid.
That's the reason why liquid
fuel reactors are attractive.
And that is, the
online quick processing
makes them relatively
inexpensive.
I say that that
kind of reactor has
the potential-- $3 per kilowatt
hour-- to undersell coal.
Why?
One is-- I looked up
some estimates that
had been done over
the past decades
for building these
kinds of plants.
And I just promoted
them up to the current,
I think, 2012 dollars.
And they're in the
range of about $2
a watt capital cost recovery.
I'm sorry, $2 a watt
capital cost-- that range.
So we're in the ballpark.
But the technical reasons
have to do with, principally,
the molten fluoride salt.
Now, the name of my book
starts off with thorium,
because it's a short word.
But the real technology key
is the liquid fuel form.
The fuel, again,
is, again, fluorides
of lithium and beryllium.
Fluorine, lithium, and beryllium
all have low atomic numbers.
Good moderators, they
slow the neutrons down,
enabling reactions.
Uranium is just dissolved
in that molten salt.
The salt, of course,
has good heat transfer.
The reaction is taking
place right in it.
And so you use that molten
salt through a heat exchange.
You're external to the reactor
vessel to get the energy out.
The whole thing is an
atmospheric pressure.
There is no-- you know, a
current light water reactor
is pressurized to, maybe,
150 atmospheres of pressure.
So we have a containment
building around it,
just in case that vessel
ever explodes somehow.
That's never happened.
But we still have
a safety factor,
because of the
atmospheric pressure
of the radioactive materials.
Another nice feature
of this project
is that there's an
overheat protection that
was designed into
the original reactor.
And that is a pipe, you can
see, that would drain the salt
from the reactor vessel itself
into a specialized drain tank.
And that pipe is
plugged with salt
that is kept cool with just
a fan that blows warm or cool
air on it.
So that, if the thing
were to overheat,
or the electric
power were to fail,
or something of that nature,
that freeze pipe-- freeze
plug-- would just melt.
And the liquid would drain
out into a configuration
which can't be critical.
There's no propulse of pressure
to spew radioactive materials
everywhere.
We've talked about that.
And the places are
typically designed
so that if there was a vessel
rupture, or pipe rupture,
or something, the molten
salts should spill out and be
contained on the floor
of the containment.
Now, the other point is that
it's a low-mass project.
This original motivation
was to design a jet engine
for an airplane.
So the first reactor
designed-- second one designed
was about 1.4
meters in diameter.
It was a beryllium sphere.
And they'd actually
started to build that unit.
But they decided not to do it.
The motivation was to
have Strategic Air Command
bombers circling Russia
for months at a time,
never refueling, powered
by these kind of engines.
But eventually, the ICBMs we had
were able to supplant bombers.
And we had nuclear
submarines at sea
with missiles on them as well.
So this project never got much
beyond the first prototype
experiment on the
ground, and this design,
for which they did build
that beryllium sphere
and started on it.
Compare that to what's
going on in China right now.
You know, the construction
costs are pretty high.
This, just the dome itself,
weighs, what, 780 tons.
They're moving big pieces
of equipment around.
The same thing's
going on in Georgia
right now, where they're
building two more power
plants-- again,
Westinghouse's design.
Another point here is
that the high temperature
of these reactors generates
power much more efficiently
than the lower temperature
of today's pressurized water
reactors.
So we can actually
cut our water use,
because we're so much more
efficient at converting
high-temperature energy
to electric power.
And there are versions of this
that will actually work with--
Is that picture complete?
Not really, is it?
Hmm.
--with just air cooling.
You can do that.
Another thing that's
happening right now
is a lot of investment
at Sandia, particularly
in the super-critical
CO2 turbines.
Super-critical CO2 is a kind
of a-- just think of a liquid,
of CO2.
And you keep compressing it.
And it becomes, at certain
temperature and pressure,
a kind of a liquid
that's compressible.
And you can make a
very efficient device
to convert thermal energy
to mechanical energy
to generate power with it.
Plenty of it around.
In the US, 500 tons just would
run the whole US electric power
system for a year.
There's plenty of it.
My point is that smaller
reactors can actually
be produced in a
production line.
Today, we have Boeing aircraft
that can make a $200 million
aircraft every day.
We know how to do that.
And making aircraft
is sort of the same.
We have the same issues about
safety, about materials,
about thermodynamics.
All those things are
controlled, and result
in quality production.
The other point here is that,
if you're producing something
out of a production
line, you have
the benefit of a learning curve.
The concept here is that when
you double the number of units
produced, you
reduce the unit cost
by a certain percentage
called the learning ratio.
Typically, it's around 20%.
In the electronics, high-tech IT
industry, it's been about 50%.
OK, and University
of Chicago was
conservative in their estimate
of 10% in the nuclear industry.
But even so, that makes a
tremendous difference in cost,
when we get to producing
thousands of units,
instead of two or three, in
a production environment.
Again, we could make a--
certainly, a $70 billion a year
industry, just by
producing these units.
Suppose we were to
do that, one a day.
We could actually cut
down the-- by replacing
coal plants, the
emissions from coal
in a period of about 40 years.
So just by replacing one a day.
It's possible to do that.
The other things that we can
do with high temperatures
from these kinds of plants
are have new kinds of fuels.
So, in this example,
we're pointing out
that, although you know about
electrolysis to make hydrogen
from water, there's
also a thermal way
to do it by making
it very hot and using
a couple of catalysts--
iodine and sulfur,
or copper and chlorine--
to create hydrogen,
making use of that
high temperature.
Not electric power, necessarily.
The Honda Clarity you can
buy today runs on hydrogen.
And there are a half a dozen
hydrogen cars that you can buy.
Hydrogen is OK as a fuel.
But you've got to compress it
in a tank in order to do it.
So it doesn't-- you don't get as
much fuel in a car as you would
with gasoline.
But we can also combine hydrogen
with these kind of elements
in order to make liquid fuels.
George Olah wrote the book
about the methanol economy.
He's a big promoter of that.
Ammonia, surprisingly,
is a good fuel.
You have to control it.
Dimethylene's a substitute
for diesel fuel.
This car's been touring Europe.
It's an ammonia-powered car.
Suppose you wanted to
make carbonation fuels,
like gasoline.
Because we know how to use that.
Where do we get a
carbon source that
is environmentally friendly?
That is, other than getting
petroleum out of the ground
and burning it.
We want a renewable
sort of carbon.
Where can we get something like
that to make these products?
One is thought to be
taking it out of the air.
And people toy with
this all the time.
And the economics of it are
sort of marginal, at best.
We're thinking that
with really cheap energy
from this kind of
reactor, it might
become economically feasible.
But that's again a Sandia
project, well thought of.
Just recently, the Naval
research laboratories
demoed their process
for getting CO2 out
of seawater, rather than air.
There's a lot more CO2
per liter in seawater
than there is in air.
And that makes it
an efficient thing.
So they've done that and
demonstrated how to make fuel.
And the point here
is that the Navy
has experience
with nuclear power.
They know-- and they're
looking strictly--
they're looking
very deliberately--
to using this kind of
extraction technology
to make jet fuel at sea from
seawater and nuclear power.
And it's not a long way off.
We're talking within the decade.
This demo skid does work.
And it's been demonstrated.
And, in fact, just as a game,
they flew a model airplane
with the kind of fuel that
they manufactured this way.
So they're pretty
pleased about that.
Again, biomass is
a source of carbon.
You can get it from farming.
And if we burn that,
and it goes in the air,
it gets reabsorbed and comes
back in a lot, to the land.
So it's a zero-impact cycle.
But I say, well, don't burn it.
Just use it as the source
of the carbon atoms
you need to make the
hydrocarbon fuels.
We can make a ton of fuel
from 1.7 tons of biomass.
Around the world, we use
a lot of dung, right,
and other sorts of products,
in order to make fuel.
Same idea.
Instead of burning
them, we could use them
as sources for
carbon for synthesis.
World cattle dung-- and
people in India collect that.
But it's very labor
intensive to collect it.
I have to point out that we
have a collection process here
already.
So that could be cheap.
Again, back again
to the benefits.
A dollar more energy can
spark our economic growth,
increase our natural
productivity,
allow tax revenues to
rise, maybe improve
the government's debt situation.
Again, low cost is critical.
That's the thing we have
to watch, all the time.
One of the reasons
I've been interested
in the denatured
molten salt reactor
is to get that cost down low.
In my books and
other talks, I've
talked to all these benefits
from the liquid fuel
nuclear reactors.
All these things
are possible to do.
But I'm suggesting now that
you kind of put it off,
until we get the
economic case solved.
If we can get economic liquid
fuel nuclear reactors sold
and being produced
in mass production,
then we get a chance to having
them be accepted worldwide
and delve into these
other opportunities
to make use of that
inexpensive power.
Again, economics always
wins in the long run.
China is under way.
They're building these units.
This guy on the left is the son
of the former president, Jiang.
He's got $350 million
allocated to projects.
And he has 400 people
working on it right now,
trying to build a
molten salt cool
version, a sort of stair-step
version, by that date.
And a molten salt
reactor, per se, in 2020.
Recently, that's
been accelerated.
Here's a slide that
Jiang used in his talk.
He points out the
crisis in China today.
And that is, air pollution
has become terrible.
And the people are
very upset about it.
So his project has
been goaled to going
into commercial
production in 2024.
Of course, China's trying
one of everything, right?
They've got big dams and four
kinds of nuclear reactors
and so on.
But they're pursuing
this intensely today.
In the US, today's
environment, we can't do that.
We really cannot.
All the rules and
regulations of the NRC
are very specific to the
light water reactors we have.
And they're being
very difficult.
There's no sort of
overview risk-informed,
performance-based regulation.
It's "comply with this rule."
And that's how the
whole system works.
Cost-benefit analyses, which
are used even by the EPA,
are not used in the NRC.
The NRC says safety
is paramount.
We make no cost-benefit
trade offs.
That's the mental
attitude going in.
The idea of the nuclear
quality assurance technology,
and rules, and so on is quipped
that every nuclear reactor
design has to have a paper
that outweighs the reactor.
A lot of the quality
and assurance issues
have been substituted
for by paperwork.
And so it's quite a difficult
thing to do in the US.
TerraPower, Gates'
company, has given up.
They're in China, trying
to do the preliminary work.
Of the four or five
ventures that are in the US
today, trying to do molten
salt reactor research,
only one says they want to
try and do it in the US.
The EPA, again, has a
problem with anything
that has to do
with radioactivity.
There is sort of a
concept of as low as
reasonably achievable,
in terms of limiting
radioactive exposure to people.
And so, the problem
with that is it's
created a sort of a horror
or fear of radiation
that's been endorsed
and encapsulated
in rules and regulations
that make it-- again, it
isn't so much the
technology and the limits.
But the sort of the attitude
of people and so on that
makes it hard to get plants
licensed or research done.
So that's the situation
we have in the US.
Probably this work's
going to come to fruition
outside the US.
So that's my summary.
Low-cost clean energy from
liquid fuel nuclear reactors
has two great potentials.
One is to improve
the economics of both
the industrialized
world that could
use a little shot of GDP boost.
It could also
improve the lifestyle
and overcome the poverty
of the developing
world without
increasing pollution.
And help us solve our
energy and climate crises.
Thank you.
I'm open to questions.
AUDIENCE: So I think what I
saw in your presentation here
was that you're basing
the estimated cost
of these molten
salt reactors based
on the cost for a bunch of
experimental reactors projected
out to [INAUDIBLE] analysis.
Are there reasons why we think
that the commercially produced
reactor-- one that was
continuously running
on a experimental one-- would
actually be cheaper to run,
and cheaper to build,
than [INAUDIBLE]
light water reactors?
What are those reasons?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
The question
is that the presentation
cited some old research
papers about the costs.
Is there any reason to believe
that in today's world, that
might happen to make the
costs as low as I suggested?
I have one friend who's done a
lot of design work, ex-MIT guy
who's within the last three
or four years designing
our nuclear power plant
production facility.
And he's come up with
numbers of $0.03 to $0.05
per kilowatt hour for
a denatured molten salt
reactor that is in a design
that he's right now still got
under wraps.
But yeah, I've seen the
papers, seen the calculation.
So it's feasible.
Again, it all depends
eventually upon what
are all the sudden
rules and regulations
that come into play, if your
work is suspended for two years
while there's a hearing or
something of that nature that
drives the costs
up very rapidly.
So his estimates
are in what I would
call a rational
regulatory environment.
So that's what we would have
to achieve as well, in order
to get those costs in line.
AUDIENCE: And I have a sort
of related question, which
is, I think you
agree that in the US,
given how people feel
about nuclear power today,
we couldn't build a reactor
that wasn't obviously
much more safer
than the light water
reactors we've
built in the past.
Are there reasons to
believe that a molten salt
reactor wouldn't
potentially be safer?
One of the [INAUDIBLE] seems
to be it also would be cheaper.
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Yeah.
The question is, why would the
molten salt reactor be safer
than the light water reactor?
First thing I would say is
that the light water reactor
accidents have generally
been few and not
quite as devastating
as you might think,
beyond the Chernobyl issue.
So compared to other
energy sources,
the nuclear power, to
date, has been quite safer,
in terms of loss of life.
So it's a good source.
The molten salt
reactor is designed
with all the
experiences people have
had about passive
safety and so on.
So again, it isn't so much
that it's molten salt.
It's that molten salt enables
good engineering with fewer
systems and able to achieve the
passive safety that's needed.
So, you know, we won't
know until we actually
build them and test
them thoroughly.
But I would say universally that
people who are designing these
believe that to be
absolutely correct.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Let's say
that, in 10 years,
the people doing [INAUDIBLE]
finally have a breakthrough.
And they achieve net
positive fusion energy.
How would you compare the
liquid fuel fission reactors
to potential, say, a
Tokamak-designed fusion
reactor?
Do you think we
would actually have
a world with both of those?
Or do you think that
if fusion ever comes,
it will end up just supplanting
all the fission designs?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Well, I
think if fusion comes, great.
But it's going to be quite
a while, in any case.
The Tokamak designs are still--
people are working hard on.
There's a big project,
ITER, in Europe.
We have that facility
in California.
And then we also have private
ventures in New Jersey,
using, what do they to call
it, non-neutronic approaches--
proton on beryllium, I think.
So there's some potential for
something to happen there.
Most people don't think
it's going to happen.
But it does, wonderful.
If we have two sources, great.
I don't see the downside to
fission that a lot of people
do.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
this molten salt reactor
is less conducive
to proliferation.
But I didn't quite follow why.
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: I
didn't cover that in a talk.
But there's a lot
of comments that
have been a bit overstated.
People say, oh, you can't
make a bomb out of it,
and this and that.
Well, you know, you
can't make a bomb out
of a light water reactor.
It sits there like a plant.
But if you have the
technical skills--
like they did in India or South
or North Korea, and so on--
you can figure out how to make a
special kind of nuclear reactor
that generates, say, either
plutonium 239 from uranium 238,
or generates uranium
233 from thorium 232.
You can do that by building
a special-purpose reactor
to build material for nuclear
weapons, in both cases.
Now, the hangup with the
thorium-uranium cycle
is that it also creates
uranium 232, which
is a hazardous material in the
sense that it decays quickly
and is likely to injure
or kill the people working
on the weapons fabrication.
So it's a little harder
to use the thorium U-233
cycles to build nuclear
weapons that way.
So I would say the
denatured molten salt
reactor is highly
proliferation resistant.
But nothing is-- anyone
with enough money
and enough technology, enough
science, could do that.
But the other evidence
is that the US
did try to build a
U-233 weapon way back,
I don't know, 40, 50 years ago.
And they did one test and they
were unsatisfied and never did
again.
So that's the only technical
evidence I have for it.
So the answer,
again, in summary,
is you can build a nuclear
weapon out of almost anything,
if you have all the skills
and money and expense.
But even developing nations,
like India, Pakistan, North
Korea, and so on, were able
to build nuclear weapons
with the technologies
that exist today.
So my suggested hurdle
is that you only
build reactors that are
no more proliferation
resistant than the
one we have today,
as we don't want to increase
the probability that someone
can build a bomb.
But we can't eliminate
it, because we
have all these paths that
are in there already.
Please.
AUDIENCE: You showed
a table of costs
that compared various
forms of energy
as actually produced
today in real plants,
and then compared this
thing that we don't yet
do that you'd like
us to develop.
So I'm curious how they compare
to a few other technologies
that we don't yet
do today, but people
want to develop in wind and
solar and other renewables.
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
Now, your question
is, what other
technologies are there
that I ought to be
looking at in that table?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like, most
of those were today's cost.
And then you added this
one at the end, which is,
here's one we could develop.
And I wonder how it would
compare to other things
that you could add.
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
Well, you're
talking about things
like hydro, for example.
I didn't put hydro in the
table because we really
can't expand hydro very much.
It's a nice source.
It's relatively inexpensive.
It's not very polluting.
It's renewable.
It's green.
It's good.
But there aren't too many sites
left to do a lot of hydro.
Geothermal, I didn't
put in, because it's not
that expandable.
There aren't that
many sites where
you can get enough
geothermal energy out.
So I tried to pick just
the examples that I thought
would produce enough electricity
to make a difference.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
No, that's not
exactly my question.
My question is, you know,
here's the cost of wind,
as done right now.
Here's the cost of
solar, as done right now.
nuclear, as done right now.
None of them do it.
OK, here's the cost
of a different way
of doing in theory
that could be cheaper.
But isn't there a
different way of doing,
you know, solar, that
could be cheaper,
that people could also
develop within a decade?
Are there things like
that on the horizon?
How do they compare?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: I see.
The question is, why
didn't I sort of project
the future costs
of wind and solar
and see if it might
not be cheaper?
And, like I said, I haven't
got a good answer to that,
except to say, for example,
in the case of solar power.
And it's pretty clear
right now that photovoltaic
is going to outrun the
concentrated solar.
It's going to be less expensive.
And there is a
lot of improvement
in the cost for
photovoltaic panels.
It's down now to $1
a watt for the panel.
But the panel is only
a part of the plant.
And so the costs for the
mounting, for the heliostats
to follow the sun, all
those kinds of things
have brought the costs up to
the numbers I've suggested.
So maybe there's
some opportunity
to reduce costs there.
But again, in the case
of solar and wind,
we also have the
storage problem.
We don't have energy storage.
So we need to have some
kind of backup power
at all times for those.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I gather as
an unstated conclusion
of the talk that somehow what's
going to happen in the future
is that China is going
to actually develop
this technology and start
sending it back to us
en masse, right?
You know, here's your
two-ton, you know,
power-generation thing.
You can buy it for this much.
And here, you have it, right?
Go get it.
Here.
And so how do you develop
here in the States?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
No, you're right.
China has been
notorious at capturing
intellectual property.
In the case of the
Westinghouse arrangement,
Westinghouse is building
four AP 1000s in China.
But China required Westinghouse
to surrender all IP
to that product.
And the deal they
have is that China
is allowed to build
power and export power
plants that are 1.4
gigawatts and up.
So the AP 1,000 is a
Westinghouse product.
The AP 1,400 is a China product.
So they have the
rights to do that.
And they intend to, I think.
In fact, one of their power
companies just went public.
So the same thing would happen
with the molten salt reactor.
AUDIENCE: So that makes it
like [INAUDIBLE] to actually
make it easier, in the sense
that there is some energy
rights and energy
technology rights happening.
And unless, you know, similar
to the space technology rights,
right, that cannot facilitate
new laws and regulations
to make this go forward.
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
So I didn't quite
understand this question.
You said is it now between the
technology race and the energy
race.
But what is the question?
AUDIENCE: Is that something--
is that a simple message that
could be sold to
politicians as a reason
to change regulations
that we've tried?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
I'm trying.
I have a whole other
topic I've been working
on called radiation
is safe within limits.
And at the end of the
talk, you can pick up
one of these little brochures.
I'm trying to get the
public to understand
the difference between the
real harm from radiation
and the regulatory
rules that deal with it.
But I don't quite
know how to get
the politicians to agree yet.
AUDIENCE: So I think the
thrust to this argument
is that the thrust of your talk
seemed to be very fatalistic.
China's going to do it.
And that's the end of it,
without an exhortation that we
should do something to better
change that, which is, I think,
perhaps we all expected to hear.
AUDIENCE: If somebody's
going to-- sorry.
If somebody, you know,
in China or anyplace else
is going to invent this
reactor, and it's going to work,
and it's going to be cheaper
than coal-- [INAUDIBLE]
take over the world?
Why not be optimistic?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
Right, good point.
If we're trying to solve
the world's CO2 problem,
does it matter whether China
solves it or the US solves it?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: The reactor with
which I am somewhat familiar
is the research reactor at MIT.
And they're routinely getting
spreads, shutdowns, emergency
shutdowns due to various
monitoring glitches
and all sorts of things
they're doing for tests.
And the model that you
showed a sketch of is dumping
a liquid-only-when-hot fuel
into a tank for it to solidify
in, as far as I can tell.
It seems that would be
burdensome to go back
into operation after
such a shutdown.
Is that something that,
as far as you know,
has been looked at?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Sure,
they're looking at all that.
I'm sure that the design
would try to keep it warm.
First of all, it's got-- it has
a lot of fission product decay.
It's going to take a long
time before that salt would
get cool enough to
actually become a solid.
And you'd probably want to have
some external heating there
to keep it from getting
solid, because it would make
it hard to restart
with some salt in all
the pumps and things.
So it could be quite a problem--
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
I'm sorry.
As you pull off the cap,
whenever safety is established,
and dump it back into the
reaction chamber, effectively?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Well,
you have to repump it.
If it all solidified,
I don't know
how you'd get it restarted.
But yeah, those kinds
of issues are up front
with all the people who are
working on those projects.
AUDIENCE: But so did
you mention that China
is spending, what, some
hundred million dollars a year
or more building
this design reactor?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
This design reactor
has a budget of $350 million
for the first five years.
That was up until
a few months ago,
when it was given a
new spike of funding--
I don't know what it is-- with
the objective of speeding up
the development.
I don't know what the
answer to that is.
We could learn.
Jiang himself is going to talk
at the American Nuclear Society
meeting in Reno.
I think it's next week.
Please.
AUDIENCE: I saw an article
in "Wired" magazine
a couple of years ago.
It really excited
me about this stuff.
And one of the things
they talked about
was, well, at least when
I see nuclear plants now,
they're all right
next to the ocean.
They're above ground.
They've got giant
cooling powers.
They kind of
mentioned that they're
kind of big terrorist targets.
Like if terrorists
had a bunch of planes,
they'd crash them into
all our power plants.
We'd be kind of out of
luck for a long time.
But no one [INAUDIBLE].
And they mentioned that some of
these thorium reactors-- maybe
the molten salt [INAUDIBLE]
ones-- they could be buried,
sort of to protect them from,
like, airplanes, I guess.
But they also mentioned that
they could be made smaller.
Like each city could
have one, sort of
keep it buried and run
for kind of a long time.
Just kind of seal it up and
use the power for a long time.
Are those two benefits to these?
Can they be buried?
And can they be much smaller?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
Yes, they-- the question
was, how do you protect
these kinds of plants
against terrorist attacks
from airplanes and so on?
Can they be buried?
And the answer,
ever since 9/11, is
that people are very
concerned about that.
So even the AP
1,000 reactor design
is capable of withstanding
an aircraft crash.
It won't collapse the dome,
nor the big tank of water
that's at the top of it.
Many of the small,
modular reactor designs,
like the one being built, were
proposed by new scale or by BW,
and are designed to
be underground power
plants, for that kind of reason.
And my co-author, Ralph
Moir, had a paper with Teller
that designed and showed an
underground molten salt reactor
plant.
So, yes, they can
be underground.
And that seems to
be the strategy
that a lot of new reactors
are going to follow.
AUDIENCE: And smaller
reactors, right?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: And
smaller reactors, yeah.
I'm proposing smaller
reactors principally-- well,
a couple reasons.
They're easier to
cool in a situation
where you have no
external power,
like we had in Fukushima.
And, you know, they're cheaper.
There's less
investment up front,
less risk capital
for the utility
for the first two or
three of these plants.
And because you get the
benefit of mass production.
We have a big engineering
controversy constantly going
on about the economy of scale
and bigger and bigger plants.
But the bigger plants sometimes
bring new problems to bear.
So if you give up
economy of scale,
you also get, in
return, the economy
of the learning
curve, because you're
going to produce more units.
So I think the smaller
units are going to win out.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Me?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Bob, a
question on your chart showing
the kilowatt cost
per kilowatt hour
of the various alternative.
Is there any attempt to
include the transmission costs?
Or are transmission
costs not relevant?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: I did
not include transmission costs.
They can make a
difference, if you
are thinking about powering
the US with renewables
from long-distance power
sources-- something like,
figure a penny per kilowatt
hour per 1,000 miles
of high-voltage DC transmission.
Keep that number in
the back of your mind
when you're trying to
design these things.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Is the nuclear waste
produced by these plants
different in some sense than
waste produced by light water
reactors?
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES: Is
the nuclear waste different
than the waste produced
by light water reactors?
Yeah, it's quite different.
The light water
reactors' waste is
in the same fuel
form it went in,
so fuel rods that are
then to be disposed
of at some future,
undetermined place.
The molten salt reactor can
continue to operate and consume
a lot of the sort of
actinides-- the heavy uranium--
the heavy elements, like
plutonium, americium,
californium, well, and so on.
So the long-lived heavy
metal, radioactive products
continue to be consumed.
Now, when you finally
stop the reactor,
you're going to have
some of those left.
So the amount of that
waste per kilowatt hour
that was generated is lower.
But you're still going to
have that kind of waste
to deal with at some point.
In addition, both
kinds of reactors
generate the fission products--
that is, the cesium or iodine
or whatever it is, xenon,
strothium, and so on,
that you've heard of--
which come from splitting
those big, heavy nuclei
of uranium and plutonium.
Both kind of reactors
generate the same kind
of fission products.
But the decay time for those is
on the order of a few hundred
years before they're really more
or less benign for handling.
So the answer is, there's less
of the waste per kilowatt hour
generated-- less of a long-life
waste per kilowatt hour
generated, about the
same amount of waste
per kilowatt hour generated
for the fission products that
have the shorter lifetimes.
AUDIENCE: So, if we were to,
say, try and replace as much
of the coal and natural
gas power infrastructure
with liquid thorium
reactors instead,
how much would we
still need in the mix
to provide peak and
on-demand power?
Because I'm assuming even
the smaller thorium plants
won't be able to come up on
demand to respond to the grid.
DR. ROBERT HARGRAVES:
Yeah, the question
is, would you need some kind
of peaking plants in addition
to the nuclear power
plants, because they
are slow to respond
to demand changes?
Well, the current
plants are slow,
basically because they
were designed that way.
And they could have been
designed to be more responsive.
But they haven't.
They are designed to recover
all their costs at full power.
So the owners of those plants
don't want to turn them down.
Now, the newer plants
will have the same issue,
in the sense of, can we-- do
we want to turn them down?
The owners will say, no, I
want to keep generating money.
So that's the real issue.
You can engineer it to make
it go-- turn it down pretty
easily.
The plants do what's
called load following.
That is, if you diminish
the load on the power plant
by turning off the lights
or breaking a pylon
and ruining the
load on the plant,
the ability to dissipate
heat disappears.
The temperature of
the reactor goes up.
And the physics of
the reactor designs
shuts it down, or slows it down.
That same principle
means it automatically
does load following.
So you can indeed have these
plants run at a lower speed
and not require backup
from, say, natural gas,
or something like that.
Thank you.